hello I'm Henry Blodgett of the Business
Insider here at Davos taking your
questions one question that was put
forth by nest naka and mr. Ben was what
do we do about the problem of Technology
taking people's jobs away by replacing
things that people used to do the simple
answer there is just to look at history
which is that this has always happened
so obviously it's a problem but it's a
problem that is solved itself over time
because people find different things to
do and certainly you go back to before
cars there were tremendous numbers of
jobs of people driving horse carts
around things like that those jobs
change they became something else so the
answer is to figure out how to retrain
workers as technology replaces jobs to
do other things in a lot of cases that
is building much more education which is
something that in the United States
we've done a terrible job of doing
lately allowing people to move around
develop new skills and helping them do
that obviously it's much easier to say
when you have the flexibility to have
some savings and go out and retrain
yourself or get more education but this
is something where government can play a
big role by emphasizing education
building the facilities to do that
creating retraining programs making
easier ways for workers to move to
different jobs and then obviously within
the United States we have a problem that
we've lost our manufacturing base that's
something that we do have to rebuild in
some way we can't all be in the services
industry which is where we are now but
the problem of Technology replacing
labor something that's gone on this is
the first job was created in the first
technology came around and it is
actually overall led to much higher
living standards and much higher average
in living standards so you know if
capitalism continues to
and we don't blend the north at problem
it will be solved but it's definitely a
challenge